i want to talk about the john cena thing
but but mark has a really funny joke
about it so i got we have to like
navigate
the joke i don't i don't want to step on
your thing
i'll try to put it out like tomorrow or
something okay fine as long as you think
you'll get it out
we just have mark do the joke no oh the
way you do it for comics not like hey
guys
i don't want to ruin a thing i don't
want everyone to think but okay but so
john cena
had this thing uh where he basically had
to apologize to china
for saying that taiwan was a country
right and uh
and he's basically doing it in in uh
mandarin
did you see the apology the apology he's
doing in mandarin bro
yeah so he's apologizing to them and
mandarin and obviously this is you know
going to piss americans off and if we're
talking about
really why we're pissed off it's because
we feel china coming
oh yeah you're getting it like if i'm
being honest if you could poke out john
cena
yeah that's that's a big cut out bro
been telling us
what i've been telling you what the
china's coming yeah he's been saying
he's gonna side with china like they
want his black ass
yeah yeah that's a good point yeah
when it starts they don't want numbers
actually that's a good point
yeah you don't even got and you commit
half the murder
statistic let's just look at the numbers
oh ben shapiro did we get that right
basically don't want no smoke with china
right no no no no no no
why has he calculated some [ __ ] there
hmm
take that
and you know it's always [ __ ] chyna but
um
and then we're gonna go into some other
[ __ ] later about that but uh but uh but
what was interesting about this one is
that like this one like
really hurt because you really seen a
dude get like bent
over to apologize right and the reason
he had to do it is because he's out
there promoting the new fast and furious
movie
right and because there's no dvd sales
the way that movies make up those sales
is from foreign box offices
right before i guess i am really good
[ __ ] about foreign box office that much
but now since you lost so much money
from no dvd sales and a year of pandemic
and the euro pandemic obviously you're
not gonna make no money because people
aren't going out to movies like they
were which i haven't
lately and it's lit and fast and fuse is
huge out there yeah it's
way better they made a whole movie in
tokyo exactly
exactly it's massive out there because
action movies
are so easily translatable yeah you
don't need comedy doesn't do well
internationally
no it does though accents and stuff like
that they do but car crashes these types
of things
are so easy to translate the same way we
love their kung fu movies
exactly any type of action you could run
it back over here so boom
it works perfectly and i bet the theater
or the the not the theater it's called
the
production company the the studio the
studio the studio is probably going to
lose
hundreds of millions of dollars i think
china only lets in a certain amount of
movies a year too
how many they only let in i don't
actually know the exact number but it's
small it's like 15 to 20.
foreign foreign movies a year yeah all
right maybe american movies but
fair enough yeah so if you're one of
those movies you get access to 1.3
billion people and they have to review
it they go through this whole process
and they make you edit it there's
certain scenes they'll make you cut that
[ __ ] control the promotional stuff
exactly but trying to figure some [ __ ]
out they figured out that the way that
you control america is with greed
we are so [ __ ] greedy we will do
anything for money anything we will sell
our own souls for [ __ ] money is
absolutely disgusting
and they finally got money we let them
get some money we had them making all
our [ __ ] toys and shirts and all this
[ __ ] until they got enough money to
start abusing us and that's how
it's a it's a new form of like economic
colonialism
and i think we were the starters of that
[ __ ] low-key yeah like we were the
biggest buying power in the world
yeah and then all of a sudden they're
like oh that buying [ __ ] economically
it's a great term
but i bet it's been coined before right
yeah that's always sold out
so we saw all the south america central
america that's what we did yeah we going
to the leaders we go yo do you want a
ton of money to sell out your country's
resources
yeah yeah so it's it sucks if we're
being honest
about it we feel china coming and that's
why it stings a little bit more
like if another country was like yo if
honduras came to us and they were like
yo
yeah you recognize el salvador
don't recognize el salvador and john
cena was like yo
lo siento el salvador in the spanish
no [ __ ] definitely don't exist but the
fact that it's
the guy who's on your heels yeah that
stings a little bit more yeah i'm going
to defend john cena a little bit
go go i think that's the argument
when you're the star of a movie the
number of people
that are that you're responsible for is
crazy yeah think about the crew
the other actors who are less famous
than you less starring roles than you
yeah the [ __ ] editors all it's like
thousands of people involved in the play
yeah yeah you slip up one time and then
your bosses are saying yo you're [ __ ]
up a thousand people's money
you can make these people most of whom
you actually know and touch on an
everyday basis
better by just saying sorry yeah i've
been 100
you've seen me be like all right man let
me [ __ ] apologize that's probably
bunch of people
that's how they're going to guilt you
because they're like look at all the key
grips that make a living
what is interesting is is
john's probably got movies about to come
out and deal's already been signed
yeah yeah and john is not going to be in
some like
romantic theatrical experiences they
already have channing tatum which is
basically just
it's just less steroids yeah
so so he's basically looking i imagine
they're like yo fam
you every one of the movies you make
could be in china if you don't apologize
you're not gonna get none of that
chinese money
and the studio might go we can't pay 200
million dollars from a movie if we're
not gonna get a hundred million from
china
we can't finance your films and china
holds grudges
this is the other thing i didn't realize
like this oh yeah that's every kung fu
movie right a [ __ ] disrespects
him a hundred years later
right a hundred years later he'll be
training for that [ __ ] and then he go
[ __ ] up the great grandson right
grudges is their [ __ ] it's crazy in the
fridge even a [ __ ] in the ring
the well remember that [ __ ] in the well
they called the garage or some [ __ ] like
this yes
yeah right they stayed in a house
parasite
yeah oh yeah right they just stay in the
house tight about that [ __ ] dude
grudges is their [ __ ] yeah that whole
movie was that
yeah they've been plotting to take over
america since the opioid crisis
that's what's how you're talking about
brother they're doing the [ __ ]
sleeper cells the opioid crisis
parasite parasite did you use that part
of the
in the in the joke about like how china
the
like we trying to see asians is
different but china is like did you use
it or not i tried it yeah
did it work or yeah yeah okay you cut it
out can we say it now yeah please
i was like we here we are looking racist
if we don't know the difference between
different asian people and china's like
it's all
issues it's all china taiwan is china
like next time i get
somebody says i'm racist because i call
an asian chinese i'm like i'm doing what
china wants yeah okay
i'm out here trying to get my [ __ ]
podcast deal with father
what is tibet what even is tibet
yo why does china want shitty land so
much bro